ma perché devi avere sempre dei problemi
quando parto con i video sotto toccata è
già non è che dai no no a tutti ragazzi
e benvenuti a questo video sono vari j
ed oggi siamo tornati su sapevo io cav h
dai zia supremo regimi per questo
episodio per favore dopo tutti
soddisfatti ora dei suoi primi ragazzi
abbiamo finiti meli di oggi anche perché
non non sono riuscito a trovare una roba
decente
nell'ultimo episodio hanno trovato
alcune rob è veramente uscente e selena
non si è divertita quindi facciamo a
divertire today ti stai divertendo
quanto è difficile suo livello
ma cosa stavamo bisogno cosa aperto
aperto livello a casa in realtà non ho
capito eh vabbè quante spine ok no pgt
perfetto desio desio desio una decente
questo era perfetto io ci provo l'ultima
volta poi porca eva se non riesco a fare
il primo livello di oggi si prospetta
una grandissima già una propria c'è una
bomba ma io non lavoro ma non avevo
visto ma non me n'ero accorto mai nella
vita c'è un deficiente
beh non è che si è andato tanto meglio
ma non sa perfetto
ma dài dài cielo quasi porca vacca è
difficilissimo però forse ce la faccio
scherzavo è la madonna superman lo
spiantato forte ok
questo è un uomo questo è buono cosa try
again
ma tu padre mappa try again tua sorella
morta ma [ __ ] a dio
ma come puoi farmi sono arrivato almeno
quando arrivò con me vigia non vinco
ammazzati ho già capito il suo che che
non va bene lo stesso episodio solaio i
scape the box c'è una roba decente fatta
recentemente almeno me magari non far
arrivare le spade nel momento giusto
sublime allora sembri un vecchio che
cerca di scopare anni fa nelle cose
della signora perché ogni lotto sono più
attenzioni su ocarina di ciò che nei
fatti sono chiudere in avanti niente non
sai fare neanche quello porca la
repubblica fermiamoci cambiamo ci
cambiamo c o non è stato così difficile
all'inizio ti fanno subito ai deriu to
win a idee io non so cosa significa
forse ti sfido a vincere credo sia
e stata proprio difficile una cosa o da
brava d'assi non è esattamente il modo
di guidare una macchina da corsa ma boh
c'è un motivo se il modo in cui ci si
siede sulle macchine non è quello però
continua a fare come vuoi zio table
slide mica faccio veramente già faccio
pagare veniva armati in questi mi chiami
ci metto pure di impegno che proviamoci
spero che mi è arrivata la pizza ma è il
momento sbagliato per la pizza o le
merda della merda la prima bit
dai che mi si prenda la pizza sia
facciamo una roba decente iniqua su su
su forza mista casca la pizza madonna
sarà un casino guarda gli alpini al caso
la pizza che tanto sei abbastanza ott da
riuscirci nel meter che che sta facendo
già agiate lo slide minchiam ero
dimenticato allo ragazzi vi spiego una
roba nel mentre che mi hanno consegnato
la pizza lastego metri gioco bellissimo
sarà infatti dai quotidiani by fa vj
mentre gioca a debiti mentre mi stavano
consegnando la pizza
mi hanno passato la pizza e c'erano due
fattorini uno mi ha consegnato la pizza
e uno mi ha consegnato il sushi che
proveniva da un suscito gli ordino
spesso sapete quando io prendo il sushi
che lo dicono i video ecco lo prendo
sempre a quel ristorante lì c'era quello
che mi ha consigliato la pizza è quello
che mi ha consegnato sushi solo chi ha
ordinato solo la pizza quindi come
caccia che mi è arrivato anche il sushi
e ho detto adesso vedo che ho sbagliato
le ordinati tutti e due
dammi lo stesso suu kyi non meno mangerò
mai però vale d'angolo e quindi io ho
presi tutti e due e li ho portati dentro
solo dopo mi sono accorto che il secondo
ordine bollo del sushi
ovviamente non era mio c'è un altro nome
sopra quel tipo me l'ha dato a me come
se fosse va beh quindi adesso io sia la
pizza che sushi sushi però di un altro
che non mangerà stasera perché mi ha
regalato a me ho provato a chiamarlo
tipo per consegnargli un sushi e poi
adesso cambio lavoro faccio fattorino
per just eat solo che mi sta cagando i
cazzi tuoi
purtroppo trovo altro signori paese nel
riconsegno il sushi faccio il video di
dio che vado a consegnargli sugli sci
bellissima no porca eva sofficissimo
sempre un problema ecco i centrali buchi
zia a dai frate impegnati vite a premi
4.000 rischi che ti guardano fai un
livello decente a mettersi emozionato
quando ho detto sta frase bra sempre
così devi giocare non avendo una volta
negli anni chiama del tipo del sushi che
lo chiamo un'ultima volta faccio st
buona azione l'ultima volta che sono
mica cazzi suoi
rock che il rock chase scusate sto male
rock nel senso che la roccia che se lo
possono inseguimento ansoldi batteria
però adesso ci siamo cazzi tuoi
o meglio io e mamma rai
tanta roba tanta roba più miti e umidi
la pizza e umida troppo aspettano altre
nottata ramen tanto ramen cazzo è un pd
mi chiamo sopra sia pro però centro i
buchi che un piacere vi si fredda la
pizza li mortacci mian bottle flip
butterfly feinbatt decente vado a
mangiare la pizza madonna a parte che è
caduto in piedi al contrario però dove
sta dove si stava fermando sul puntino
dico solo questo
[Musica]
pensavo così è nata bene sono morto
anch'io di sotto a caso dei andrò morire
io prove e morto questo è morto chi è
qual è la quarta nei ma non ha fatto non
so se non sapete fare i livelli non li
fate fate quelli che consegnano suscita
gestiti che non sanno consegnarlo è però
almeno hardest pulite
[Musica]
c'è un sacco di competizione ultimamente
su building parkour just a new wave
yamaha provenienti aveva giocato i mille
dove devi fare b dove devi fare parkour
tra gli edifici ed erano tutti i livelli
di questo zio che questa come una merda
green screen gerry scotti fa chi è a dai
jerry calà misyaf re della pizza jerry
sarà la pizza più gelata della vita lo
so già io sono il cafasso livello ma
purtroppo c'è una moneta di maschio
davamo sappiamo né da subito e pirla ma
non lavorista perché mi sa che non ci
arrivo però vabbè tenterò di arrivarci
in tutti i modi ma non ci arriverò mai o
forse sì
pacchia ragazzi direi l'ultimo rai ha
pronunciato chiare by names terni in
impossible quadro che fanno il prossimo
as tecniche non gioca degli sprechi vi
fate riposare a step nymex alano va bene
papà vegas salva innata asia destra nata
va ai papà vegas belli bravo papà ma
giuseppe non si trova e si vede mai la
panda d'oro di cui oraria e papà
impegnati per l'amor di dio si papa si
parla si parla sembra un porno
bruttissimo perfetto wilson ai ragazzi e
dopo sussurri e posso dire che posso
concludere finito anche perché la pizza
sono diventato un pezzo di ghiaccio
degno del polo nord vero papà che i
ragazzi spero che vi sia piaciuto spero
che tipo mi risponde al telefono perché
sono su si muovano veramente io chi s'è
visto s'è visto
i ragazzi mi piace anche la risoluzione
come visto andare speziale cento
significa che ci vediamo al prossimo
video schede ragazzi
[Musica]